日本の食べ物には野菜がない
ので、みなさん、これは私の兄弟のライアン
または大佐
です。彼がここにいる間、別のビデオを作成する時間があまりないので
、一緒にビデオを作ったら面白いと思いました。
紹介してくれませんか。
これは私の兄のライアンです。彼は私
より1年半年上で、私たち
には氷があります。私たちに
は非常に異なる
考え方や操作方法、さまざまな
スキルセット、さまざまな興味があります。 私たち
はあなたの職業から始めることができるので、
明らかに私はYouTubeをやっています。私はコンテンツクリエーターです。
彼は
サンフランシスコとシリコンバレーのスタートアップ企業であるClearyのCEOであり、
Clearyと
は何かをみんなに伝えてみませんか。
内部ツールの
生産性プラットフォームなので、ソフトウェアに基づいているので
、フレームから外れているかもしれません
。TwitterやGoogle、
uberやairbnbの
ように、従業員が親切にするためのツールを作成しています。
日常の生産性
に関する情報をオフィスで見つけ
て、それに似たツールを構築しているので、すべての会社
がこれらのテストにアクセスできるようになっています。
日本の大学
で働くのは、会社
の誰かのメールアドレスを見つけるのがとても大変でした。
そういうことは、ほとんどの会社にとっては問題
だと思いますが、
時間がかかり、親切です。
必要以上に複雑なので、あなたの会社
とあなたの会社の目的は、
そのような市場の権利に対処する
ことです。それは私たちが
できることです。 会社で起こっている
ニュースや発表との出会いや好きなこと
あなたの利益がどんな種類
のウィキ情報であるか知りたいのですが、彼ら
はたくさんのものを蓄積しているだけで
、見つけるのは本当に難しいです
簡単なナビゲーションツールを使用して、さまざまなプラットフォームの情報にアクセスできるシステム
があります。あなたの
会社はあなたのソフトウェアを使用していますか？はい、私たちは
彼らの内部を構築した正方形のように作業しました
プラットフォームとフレックスポートなので
、私たちが一緒に仕事をした大きなものの2つです。
あなたの
好きな食事は何ですか。私は実際に
日本食はそれほど良いとは
思いません。
多くの人が本当に日本食が好きなのか教えてくれます
が、嫌いではありません。
大丈夫だと思いますが
、韓国料理、中国料理、ベトナム料理
はどれ
もまあまあまあまあまあまあまあまあまあ面白いと思います。
日本食には野菜が含まれていないことを拡張します。それは
いつも
ご飯のようで、カツのよう
に側面にレタスがあり
ます。 鉱石私は純粋さが好きです私
は物のようですそしてあなたはそれが
米のようでありそして1つのもののようにカツほとんどの
人は日本食は
彼らのような最高のmmmのようだと
思います 多くの人が
2009年に初めて日本の木が最高だと言うでしょう
、そして私は野菜のようにほとんど食べないのが
好きですそれは逆のようだと私は知っていますそして私
は多くの人々とよく比較しました
最も
興味深いのは、コーネル大学を卒業し
た直後に何をしたかについてもう少し話してみませんか。それは
、スタートアップのような
ものです。 趣味うーん
、それから
友達の一人が北京に引っ越してきたので中国語に
なり、1
年半ほど前に
韓国で4ヶ月間離れて北京に
引っ越してしまいました。 言わないで
中国語の何かがまたすぐに本物になるので
、私はアメリカの
洗濯機のメールだと言うことができます。過去に何度も聞いた
ことがあるので、中国語の発音については何も知りません
が、聞いたことがある人は誰でも、聞いたことがある中国語を話し
ます。 私の兄の発音は
本当に良いと言っているので、あなたが
中国語を勉強したとき、これは面白いかもしれません。
私のチャンネルや語学
学習者を見る人のほとんどは日本語を学んでいますが
、私が発音を教えているので
、教室で中国語を学んだことはあります
か？ 朝の通勤
中に車のようにたくさんのテープを使っ
ていたので
、ネイティブのスピーチにしか触れなかった
ことを思い出してください。私が教えたいことの1つは、それは
一種の物議を醸すアイデアですが、
できるだけネイティブに聞こえるに
は、
聞いている外国語の90％が外国語である
、または言語を話す教室環境に身を置かないことが
最善です。 その環境よりも
ネイティブのスピーチを聞くのが一番いいので
、あなたが取ったアプローチはそう
です私はほとんどの
人とは非常に異なる経験を中国
で学んだと思います
私たちが高校生だったときに知っているように、教室の設定で
それを学ぶの
は、部屋に30人の人がいるようなスペイン語を学ぶようなもので、
誰も本当に何も知らないようなものです。
あなたが話している人
は、mm-hmmという言語を話す方法を知らない他の誰かと話しているだけな
ので、それは一種の役に立たないものと呼ばれてい
ます。  「その教室の
設定に頻繁にいます、そして私は実際に
これが日本でさらに流行していると思い
ますあなたが
言語に非常に情熱的であるにもかかわらず、t
のようにできるだけ流暢に聞こえようとすることについてほとんど汚名があります
ネイティブのような
アクセントで話したいと思っている人はあなたを見て、あなたの
ような人は私が好きな人がこの男を見て
とても頑張っ
ています
絶対に最小限の努力よりも、人々
は
あなたがそれが真実であることを知っているようにパパに感謝しているように感じるでしょうそしてそれは
お互いに別の理由
です 高校の
設定はそこにいなければならないからです
ええそれが
おそらく主な要素だと思います
が
、誰もが
言語に非常に情熱を持っていても、仲間に見られている要素があると思います
まだ少しあります いわば
流れを乱したくない
ので
、けいお大学で日本語を勉強し
ていても、何よりも発音に集中し
ていて、IIを覚えています。
いつも先生
に各単語の高低アクセントを教えてもらいたいと
思っていたのですが
、教室にいる他の人と同じように悪臭を放つようになりました
。
日本を学びたいと思っていたのですが、彼らは
まだ
あなたの能力を最大限に発揮する能力に影響を与える可能性のあるピアプレッシャーの
ようなもの
です私は日本の教室でそれを学びました
家庭教師
ええ、でもそれは家庭教師のようで、
あなたは同性愛者かもしれません。それは
家庭教師だったので、私が行く
ようなものでした。
6週間のスティント
と4か月のスティントのように
ディップするのが
好きなので
、
周りに他の人がいなかったので、先生との直接の会話のように長くはしませんでした。 だから私は
薄くします kあなたはプライベートチューターとの2時間のセッションを知っています
ええこれは
おそらく1ヶ月のようなもので
はないかもしれませんええおそらく2週間のような
教室の設定ですええそして
私は発音が私にドリルダウンされたことに同意し
ます ええ非常によくええええ
あなたは非ネイティブの中国語にさらされたことはありませ
んええほとんど
決してええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
実際に良い語彙を持っているのに十分ですmm-うーん
、私が中国にいたときに私が持っていた一般的な問題で、おそらく
数日後に上海に行くように
、私が話すときに再びそれがあるでしょう
中国語では、私は
流暢か流暢ではないと
思いますが、
実際にはほとんど何も知らないので、発音に
集中した
ので、実際よりもはるかに多くのことを知っていると思うかもしれません。
私のピークのようにたった4、5ヶ月の学習でした私の
ピークの語彙私はおそらく
500語
を知っていましたmm-うーん今私はおそらくそれを知っています100私
はアメリカで生まれた日本人の女の子
を知っていました
彼女の両親ですが、彼女は私がし
た言語を学ぶのに非常に似たアプローチをとっ
ていたので、彼女は一種
の独学で、発音に集中して
いましたが、彼女の
外見は100％日本語で、彼女が来
たように彼女の話を聞いたのを覚えています
彼女が良い発音をしていたので、人々が彼女に何かを言うだろうとあなたが知っているのと同じことが起こります
、そして人々は
彼女が何を言っているのかわからなかったので、そして彼女が知らなかったのでこれらすべてのことですぐに戻ってきます
彼らが何を言っているのかは知っていますが、彼女は
日本人があなたの何が悪い
のかと思っていたようです
ツアーの合計、
または
ほとんどが家庭教師なしでさまざまなことをする
前に、私も行く前に何かをしまし
た、そしてそれから私はちょうど
それがそれとして始まるのを感じることができるようにこの変曲点にぶつかっただけでした 少し加速し
て話す能力
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ これは忘れてしまいました
どういうわけか私は中国語の女の子のようにこれに会いました
mm-hmそして私たちのように彼女は
英語を
話せませんでし
た 中国語ええ、私
はちょうど私たちが1つの日付のように行ったのが好きですまたは
多分2つまたは3つは
覚えていませんが、基本的に
はある時点で覚えているようにそれは
土曜日のようだった
と思います -うーん
、彷徨うようなものです ソウルの周り
私たちが何をしていたかは覚えていませんが、
それは私の人生で最初で最後で
唯一の時間
でした。
その経験の最初で最後のMerceを手に入れてください。
それは非常に興味深く、あなたが知っている限り、私がまったくコミュニケーションをとることができたという事実
に非常に驚いたことを覚えているとは思いません。
私が言っていることは、
私が過去6か月間で実際に多くのことを学んだように
、これは私が二度とやらないと言った良い
ことです。
簡単に話し
たことがありますが、具体的には
、語学
学習全般については、いわば
自分の体重を超えてパンチするのが一番だと思います。
それが
あなたを没頭させているかどうか そのような環境で
は、私たちは言語を話すことを余儀なくされますが、
私が人々に勧めるもう1つの
ことは
、同じ映画を何度も何度も繰り返して映画を見るということです。
途中で語彙を学ぶのか
、最初にすべての語彙を学んで
から映画を見るのか、それぞれの
アプローチには独自のメリットが
あると思いますが、確かに経験したことの1つ
は、日本人がいたことです。
映画それは12人の日本人と呼ばれて
います日本人は知ってい
ますねねえはい私はジムで私を見るのは映画の名前ですが、
私が持っていたDVDのコピーに
は字幕がなく
、法廷ドラマであり、私は見つけました
毎日見ているだけで、
文字通り初級の日本語を取っているのに、
新しい言葉を拾っていて、見た目と同じように
、さまざまな文法のポイントが何を意味するのかを理解していたことに
気づきました。  y何が起こっているのかを理解する
ように強制するのと同じように、その環境に没頭する
ので、ネイティブ
スピーチは非常に重要
です。 実際に
は特に集中するようなものではないかもしれないので
、その教室の設定で、
ネイティブでないスピーチをたくさん聞いて
いる場合は、
他の人が
私の声を残念に思っている悪いパターンを覚えている可能性が高いです 行き始めましたが、
それは良い戦略です。
明らかに没頭することは
非常に重要ですが、メディアだけ
でも非常に良い戦略です。あなたが思っている
以上に取り上げて、
強制されたときに出力を行う あなた
は私の兄弟があなた
がそこにいることをあなたが知っているよりもあなたが知っていることに気付くかもしれ
ませんあなたは実際に彼があなたの最高の兄弟であると言うでしょ
う 兄を連れて
行って美味しいものを食べに行かなくてはなりませんでした
が、少なくともこの動画
が視聴者に何らかの価値をもたらすことを願っていますので
、次の動画を出すことができなかったことをご理解
いただきありがとうございます。
次のコメディービデオにワクワクすることを願っています
ので、ご覧いただきありがとう
ございます。行く前に言いたいことは、
いつもご飯とカツのようです。